these Copperhead pipes are an
alternative to ventilators and they're
used in these hand-built servers this is
the Hamburg headquarters of the startup
company proto net the product is the
focal point of the in-house cafe to the
company calls it the easiest server in
the world the idea is to provide an
alternative to saving data on
centralized large computing centers now
that cloud computing is upon us many
people are worried about leaving their
data in the hands of others due to the
threat of hacking re gel vay has
experienced that himself bus bus stop us
yet is this the first thing I feel when
I see an email or the news that
something has been hacked is fear has
the starburst gag disc what's out there
how much do I need to lock up again at
the ants how many other parts worse do I
have to change or how many other logins
do I have to block if you it's a bit
like losing your wallet hitsugi amozesh
man does his head missing via these and
ina spot money for the N giove and his
30 employees want to turn that fear into
profit the small server is designed to
decentralize the internet the Englanders
indeed cyclists we believe that
decentralizing the internet will solve a
lot of problems it's about safety look
at these huge hacking attacks or that
massive surveillance scandal if we were
in a decentralized world it would be
practically impossible to hack hundreds
of millions of accounts honored me on
from our cards n fits with Eggman
programming servers has been limited to
IT specialists in the past and a gel
they wants to change that neither box
has ems this box is called ims if i go
to ims that's ims protonate info the URL
is on the info sheet then this web page
loads up and this page comes directly
from this box here excellent is a box
that allows video phoning without large
providers such as Skype
hello yang 11 but he's faced criticism
for his basic technology Suzie Shahi da
knife ahead if there's always a
compromise between security and
simplicity if you want absolute security
you need systems which are hard to use
and very hard to explain the IT
department of Hamburg University is
located close by a pioneer of data
security in Germany is professor Klaus
von Stein he's observed developments in
the internet over years and says there
would be advantages if it were more
decentralized of the dee hoty autumn
days automatic attacks from large
networks are particularly efficient if
there's a single address to focus on who
know me where a lot of data can be
downloaded as a hobby I'm Dan Coakley
field I have one come so spreading the
data over smaller decentralized machines
would be useful the attackers would have
to work a lot harder and the I'm glad I
hadn't female fans who look iDEN Giove
is aiming to attract business from
potential customers such as legal firms
advertising agencies or engineering
consultancies unusually he also wants as
many competitors as possible
being on my festa understood we believe
that this diversified world will happen
one could work but if it ends up as a
monoculture there'll be one kind of
server one kind of attack and all of a
sudden everything can be hacked that's
not what we want unger devon they want
to introduce stability on liberty
through diversity why overnight do ki
Fateh HW tate and fire rambling the NSA
affair and the debater secured data has
been a boost for business jal ver says
he's now selling forty serve as a month
instead of two